hi I'm Pluto hi and I'm I'm not I'm not
a planet you probably feel bad for Pluto
don't you you're probably you're like oh
come on Charlie it just wants to be a
planet who cares about a bunch of mean
astronomers arbitrary classification
decisions
you're still a planet in my heart Pluto
or guess what today Pluto is going to
get its comeuppance I mean no I'm not
going to try and argue that it should be
called a planet and not want to go
against science but I am going to try
and explain why Pluto's apparent
demotion to dwarf planet isn't quite as
bad as it might seem in this episode Oh
fancy it's fun science fun science is
the science of fun yeah now before we
get too deep into Pluto itself let's
take a look at how it and the rest of
the solar system was born about four
billion years ago gravity did what
gravity likes to do and pull together an
awful lot of gas and dust most of which
form to create our Sun and you can think
of the Sun sort of like a parent trying
its best to keep this new family
together because this early solar system
was chaos floating around the Sun with
these little things called planetesimals
sort of like planetary toddlers and just
like to your owns these planetesimals
had a habit of bumping into each other
these mini planets bash together a
combined building upon one another
eventually collecting enough material to
form planets sized bodies these bodies
then pulled in the surrounding debris
clearing out their respective areas of
space and thus the solar system was
formed so what exactly does the creation
of the solar system have to do with
whether or not we call Pluto a planet or
to explain that let's hear what the
definition of a planet actually is a
planet is a celestial body that a is in
orbit around the Sun B has sufficient
mass for its self gravity to overcome
rigid body forces and maintain a
hydrostatic equilibrium shape it's also
sorry could I just pop in for a
membership so according to everything
stated so far Pluto would be considered
a planet it's in space it's in orbit
around the Sun
it's round oh good however however a
planet is also see a celestial body that
clears the neighborhood around its orbit
exactly so unlike the planets which did
clear out their regions of space as they
were forming Pluto exists in one of the
busier regions of space the Kuiper belt
and thus does not qualify for planetary
status now if Pluto was the only one of
its kind maybe it would still be
considered a planet but there are many
other bodies like it in the solar system
like Eris which is about the same size
as Pluto and Ceres which is much closer
to us than Pluto it's in the asteroid
belt just beyond Mars so for all of
these a new category was created the
dwarf planets so no Pluto wasn't demoted
just because it's small although if it
was a bit bigger than maybe it would
have cleared out its region of the solar
system and grown into a real planet just
saying not to rub it in or anything but
Pluto is very tiny compared to the
planets in fact it's only 66 percent the
diameter of the moon and is smaller than
six other moons in the solar system it's
even tiny compared to one of his own
moutains chair on which is nearly half
of Pluto size I would be like if our
moon was this big
while our current understanding of Pluto
might have relegated it to a lower
status personally a much happier living
in this time purely because back when
Pluto was a planet the highest
resolution image we had of it was this
but when the New Horizons craft did a
flyby in 2016 it was revealed to look
like this this flyby did confirm the
Pluto is slightly bigger than we thought
which is one plus for it but the biggest
discovery was that well maybe you
already know I'm going to say here it
has a giant heart on it it's pretty
freaking cute
basically you shouldn't feel bad for
Pluto where before it was the ninth
planet the smallest and most irregular
one of them all now it's the head of its
own group the dwarf planets it's the
biggest of all of them and the first of
its kind no longer number nine the
number one so feel sorry for Pluto all
you like but I think it's got an awful
lot going for it thank you
very much thank you Charlie really
cheered up this little planet still not
a planet whoo science over it thank you
very much for watching everyone also big
thanks to my friends hazel and Dodie for
making appearances in this video there
are more of these fun science videos
coming as part of this mini series three
more so keep your eyes peeled and also
if you like fun science why not
experience it in book form wow did you
do the focus pool yeah who knows it's
really good I mean I would say that I'm
very biased I rotate by promises good
and if you'd like a copy there are links
to buy it in the description out right
now it's real look at that it's really
good fine thanks fine you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool